after an historic tweet after leaking
into a fifth day after a night of drama
and confrontation it was 15th time lucky
for Kevin McCarthy
the Californian Republican finally
flipped enough votes to secure the
position as Speaker of the U.S House of
Representative
a Speaker of the House
is not to my party
my conference
or even our Congress
my responsibility
our responsibility
is to our country
he told everyone he had the votes to win
on the 14th round he didn't two votes of
present Gates
Gates essentially blocked his way to the
chair as he fell short of the number of
votes required by one
it led to incredible scenes on the house
floor with the two being confronted by
colleagues words were exchanged fingers
pointed and physical confrontation
apparently avoided as one Congressman
had to be held back by colleagues
the conversations continued and suddenly
a vote to adjourn to Monday was rejected
McCarthy wanted to go again the scene
summed up by one Democrat as he offered
his party's nominee for the Post Madam
clerk I Rise to say wow
as the voting began again one
congresswoman expressed her exasperation
at the extended process
and then it was done McCarthy finally
became speaker of the 118th Congress
Kevin McCarthy moved into the speaker's
office earlier this week but several
times in the chamber it looked premature
a group of ultra conservatives blocked
his elevation but slowly he ground them
down offering a rafter concessions
including a change of rules and who
could challenge the speaker and the
promise of seats on influential
committees
Democrats congratulated McCarthy on his
win but warned he faces problems to
control his own party one Republican
said the issues of the last few days
will have no impact on his party's
long-term prospects the 2024
presidential election creeping ever
closer uh I think it's been hard on the
party uh and a little bit frustrating
but I don't think it's left a scar I
don't think it's anything permanent and
as I've said a number of times as well
six months from now Nolan will be
thinking about this and that could be an
issue for Kevin McCarthy he has an
extensive agenda he wants to push
through Congress but to do that he needs
a United party and it has been anything
but in the last few days and hours Alan
Fisher Al Jazeera on Capitol Hill in
Washington